we're gonna blow your and - lisa rinna
stands hard for Kelly Ripa's husband
Mark Consuelos Kelly posted this
shirtless snap of her leading man on
Instagram Tuesday oh my god let's pause
and enjoy the six-pack shall we I love
it
anyway the Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills star said what we were all
thinking in the comments
writing simply Thank You Kelly along
with a fire emoji it's everything but
Lisa wasn't the only celeb getting all
hot and bothered over marks ocean snaps
West world star Jonathan Tucker was also
feeling it writing more of this content
please so it seems like Kelly's just
giving the people what they want
and this isn't the first time she's
shared a smoking hot shot of her hubby I
would say marriage is a blessing in
February she posted this shirtless pic
of Mark on the beach alongside the
caption man crush Monday followed by
tired of winter Tuesday enjoy the heat
hashtag daddy more like hashtag couple
goals he is incredible the Riverdale
star hasn't shied away from gushing
about his wife on the gram either she's
beautiful in 2018 he shared this
bikini-clad shot of Kelly writing sultry
Sunday with the sexy one are my fav
[Music]
[Applause]